I got to tell you and I'm not lying
about this because I don't say this
often today a lot of women that work
here at the show very excited that you
were coming on the program you'd become
a bit of a heartthrob yeesh
I I find that completely ridiculous my
friend III I do have to say I have to
jump on mr. shorts bandwagon you know
when I was growing up when I was in high
school my dear friend Teresa Bradley had
the biggest crush on you and it had
nothing to do with your winning
personality or how funny you are which
everybody knows he is it was completely
and utterly based on looks and I do have
to say now seeing you this close and
looking into your eyes you are a very
handsome man I know
[Applause]
so
I just thought I'd say that
[Music]
I think I'm in love with you now what
you know I'll say that you've got on the
show I can you've got a real like a
rugged like a real rugged charm going
for you on this you know if rugged means
battered in and beaten up looking I
think I've kind of got that covered you
know I know I don't think that's a good
ladies and ladies like that though maybe
it's like a guy who is tough and
confident and you exude that on the show
and well you know I have I have two
brothers and they're sort of just better
looking prettier versions of me and and
my older brother Tom he never ceases to
take the opportunity to tell me how good
my acting career would actually be going
how well it would be going if I only
look like him you know it is what a nice
guy and the best didn't but you know I
was down in Shreveport I was just doing
a movie down there and a guy came by to
deliver a pizza and he said he was
really excited to be delivering pizzas
me that he and his wife were huge fans
of the show and I said oh it's great I'm
so glad you guys watch let me sign
something for you he said well actually
you know you are my wife's one wild card
I said well what what exactly is that
right and he said that I would both
accept and encourage my wife sleeping
with you and and I said well wow wow
Scotty I I really don't know what to say
to that he said yeah and the cool thing
is is now I know where you live okay
well you know I'll just take the pizza
man well it's hard for me to accept
because I've broken my nose 14 times I
do break your nose 14 times you know
look boxing player baseball posture yeah
just being an all-around knucklehead but
see that was something that happened to
me but these giant years I was born with
these and-and-and and no joke when I was
born the doctor actually did say to my
mom he suggested that they carved the
ears down a little bit because of all
the massive amounts of ridicule that I
would get yeah and this was not Beverly
Hills in 2012 one think I have like a
salami slicer there
there you go yeah
well that's crazy I know cosmetic
surgery on a baby but now yeah I'm
walking dad of course there's a lot of
zombie-killing and that must be fun but
you're your character also gets to uh
you know have a good time with the
ladies that's it you've had some sexy
what always leads to the other yeah I
mean I kind of go
zombies always lead to sex it's it's
it's funny because there's as far as our
show goes you know you can show a six
year old girl getting shot in the head
and you can show somebody getting sliced
in half with a meat cleaver but when it
comes to sex on our show there are very
specific rules and regulations as far as
non-pay cable go right and you know as
far as I remember but one of the first
scenes I ever shot with the lovely and
talented Sarah Wayne Callies
we just met and we were told to go out
into the woods together and simulate sex
so and that's always great hey nice to
meet you let's go simulate sex and I was
told as far as nudity is concerned the
only thing you're allowed to show is the
male buttocks so there I was I had to
drop trou in front of the crew that I
was going to be working with for the
next few years and they all saw my ass
and I walk out into the woods with her
and I learned the golden rule of sexual
stimulation on non-paid cable and that
is no thrusting no thrusting whatsoever
and now these rules crazy they really
they really don't these also you can see
your butt that's it but there's no
thrusting Oh interesting and I will tell
you nothing will make you feel like a
bigger pervert than having your director
and producers yell at you from behind
the camera while you're simulating sex
John no thrusting John you're thrusting
stop thrusting oh you know
you call me a douchey method actor but
I'm trying to get into it I don't know
how to ride it beat no doing grinding
not thrusting